il est têtu comme un Breton et ça tombe
bien mon invité à passer l'essentiel de
sa vie à défendre la langue et la
culture bretonne y compris au Palais
Bourbon
[Musique]
bonjour Paul Molac bonjour alors le 8
avril 2021 avec quelques collègues
députés vous vous êtes rendus sur les
marches du Palais Bourbon et vous avez
antoné ces quelques notes
[Musique]
mon petit galère
donc ça c'est l'hymne breton un Bro Goze
mazadou c'était pour célébrer l'adoption
de votre loi sur l'enseignement des
langues régionales à l'école c'est une
loi pour faire simple qui permet un
élève en Bretagne d'apprendre les maths
ou la géographie en breton ça s'appelle
l'enseignement immersif moi ce que je
veux savoir c'est ce que vous célébrer
ce jour-là sur les marches du Palais
Bourbon c'est quoi c'est une victoire
contre quoi alors je pense que c'est une
victoire de la démocratie c'est une
victoire des territoires sur la
technocratie sur la technocratie et sur
une certaine conception de la République
par Jean-Michel Blanquer par exemple
voilà de sur une norme qui serait
définie par l'État qui devrait s'imposer
à tout le monde y compris dans ce que
nous vous devez parler ou quasiment ce
que vous devez être donc on sort de la
politique la quelque part pour
s'attacher à façonner le citoyen y
compris sa culture en fonction d'une
norme qui viendrait de Paris ce qui a
été fait bien souvent et nous on dit bah
non on a aussi une langue oui mais je
parlais d'une certaine conception de la
République celle de Jean-Michel Blanquer
vous vous êtes opposé à ces violemment à
lui il était ministre de l'éducation
nationale à l'époque et il a appelé la
majorité à rejeter votre loi il a pas
été entendu non il a pas été entendu
puisque les deux tiers du groupe lrem de
l'époque a voté la loi mais c'est une
conception en fait de l'État et que
c'est l'État comme il le dit lui-même
d'ailleurs en France c'est l'État qui
fait le citoyen moi je pense qu'en
démocratie c'est le citoyen qui fait
l'état avant parler peut-être un peu
plus tard dans l'entretien mais pour en
revenir à cette hymne boutons sur les
marges du Palais Bourbon on sent chez
vous un côté un peu provocateur comme si
vous aimez bien défier l'autorité le
pouvoir central j'ai toujours été un peu
comme ça d'ailleurs mes enseignants s'en
plaignaient mais là c'est un pur hasard
c'est à dire que les collègues m'ont dit
il faudrait qu'on chante quelque chose
en breton et bon alors il y a bien des
chansons à boire mais cette ce n'est pas
le lieu et je me suis le solaire qui
doivent connaître à peu près avec
quelques paroles ça doit être le brogos
donc j'y vais c'est un symbole fort
quand même un hymne régional national
pour vous alors oui mais si vous
regardez les Gallois par exemple ça leur
pose aucun problème parce qu'on a le
même le même aire avec les mêmes paroles
eux en gallois nous en breton et ça pose
aucun problème quand il le chante là-bas
bon c'est pas tourner contre quelqu'un
c'est on dit bon bon on dit ce qu'on est
mais c'est faut pas le voir comme un
nationalisme belliqueux revengeur ou
quoi que ce soit non c'est pas ça alors
vous êtes engagé à 17 ans dans la
défense de la culture de l'identité
bretonne vous avez commencé à recueillir
des traditions orales du pays gallo d'où
vous êtes originaire et au même âge à
peu près vous vous êtes inscrit au cours
du soir pour apprendre la langue
bretonne pourquoi soudainement ce besoin
de vous tourner vers cette identité
bretonne j'avais dans mon parcours
scolaire et je m'étais un peu interrogé
sur le fait que nous étions en Bretagne
et qu'on ne parlait jamais à l'école
donc ça me paraissait un peu bizarre et
donc j'ai commencé par chercher moi-même
donc j'ai demandé à Noël quand j'étais
en cinquième par exemple un bouquin
d'histoire de Bretagne parce que bon il
y en avait pas énormément il y avait pas
énormément de bibliothèques à l'époque
et donc mes parents bon ont pris dans la
librairie du coin le et donc j'ai lu
l'histoire de Bretagne et effectivement
que j'ignorais et je crois que une
partie de mon combat il est parti de là
aussi mais et alors sur la langue
bretonne c'est une langue on la parle
encore aujourd'hui dans le Finistère par
exemple mais vous vous êtes du Morbihan
et dans votre département on parle plus
le Breton depuis 5 siècles je crois
alors pourquoi vouloir à ce point vous
raccrocher à une langue qui est plus
vraiment ancrée dans votre territoire
alors sur Ploërmel oui mais dans le
reste du Morbihan non parce que je suis
pas très loin de la zone historique si
vous voulez qu'on appelle base Bretagne
et puis comme je le dis je m'appelle
molak c'est un nombre breton je suis né
à Ploërmel c'est un nombre temps
j'habite à Taupont c'est un nombre
breton et il y a un village qui
s'appelle molak pas aussi chez vous pour
ce qui est de ce gilet que vous portez
là sous votre veste aujourd'hui c'est un
gilet breton on appelle ça le glasique
je crois vous le portez dans l'hémicycle
depuis votre élection en 2022 on vous
voit là vous le portez même sur la photo
officielle qui a été prise de vous à
l'Assemblée c'est un geste politique
mais en même temps ce gilet il fait pas
partie non plus de votre tradition
locale c'est un gilet qui vient du
Finistère de Quimper oui alors quand
j'ai vu ma question c'est est-ce que
c'est pas un peu artificiel en fait
est-ce qu'il y a pas un côté un peu
folklore derrière tout ça le problème
les traditions vous savez ça se signifie
on croit que c'est figé mais en fait non
et donc à l'Assemblée nationale je
voulais pas quelque chose qui soit noir
parce que déjà que c'est gris et que
c'est un bleu souvent profond et donc je
me suis dit il faut que je trouve
quelque chose avec un peu de couleur etc
donc chez nous il y en avait pas
vraiment ou alors en broderie donc du
coup je suis allé effectivement puiser
dans la tradition cornoyeuse ou c'est un
bleu quelquefois ça peut être rouge
d'ailleurs d'accord quand j'ai vu mon
collègue motaille et qui va de Polynésie
voilà avec sa chemise à fleurs avec son
espèce de kilt je me suis dit bon il
faut qu'on change un peu parce que
franchement là on est tous un peu ça
fait un peu corbeau quoi alors vous avez
trouvé un débouché politique à ce combat
en 2012 vous avez été investi au
législatives chez vous donc dans le
Morbihan avec le soutien du PS d'Europe
Écologie et de l'UDB l'Union
démocratique bretonne je crois qu'on est
un peu venus vous chercher mais
finalement la politique c'est un peu la
suite logique du combat que mené depuis
vos 17 ans oui mais jusque là j'avais
pas cherché forcément
c'est à dire que j'avais plutôt cherché
à
travailler dans les associations et
j'étais effectivement comme ça devenus
président de l'association pour
l'enseignement du breton à l'école
publique au niveau Bretagne et je
travaillais comme ça parce que je me
voyais pas je suis peut-être trop
indépendant pour être dans un parti
politique justement et ça je le parlais
on va en parler une fois élu à
l'Assemblée vous avez donc poursuivi
votre combat pour la défense des langues
régionales et ça a donné lieu parfois à
des prises de parole assez étonnantes on
va regarder le fait que la République
lit bien souvent la langue française
avec la citoyenneté m'a toujours paru
curieux il n'empêche que quand le
français est bien sûr la langue commune
et on le comprend bien mais je dirais
que
donc la langue de mon cœur et de mon âme
et bien le Breton ça ne fait pas moi de
moi un Français pire que les autres
pas forcément meilleur non plus
d'ailleurs mais la langue ne fait pas le
citoyen alors vous dites la langue ne
fait pas le citoyen et vous allez même
un peu plus loin dans une interview à
Ouest-France on vous définissant comme
un citoyen français de nationalité
bretonne est-ce que ça veut dire que
vous ne vous reconnaissez pas dans la
nation française
je pense que la nation française est
plurielle c'est à dire que la nation
française n'est pas le clone ou la norme
que l'État a voulu nous imposer vous
vous identifier à cette pluralité de la
nation française en tant que tel oui
bien sûr vous reconnaissez pas parce que
il faut bien faire une différence entre
ce qui est nos droits politiques que
nous exerçons ensemble et pour l'intérêt
général je l'espère ça c'est le
politique et donc je dis bien que je
suis citoyen français parce que je
m'inscris dans cette chose politique
après la nation c'est ce qui est ce qui
m'est propre et donc quand et de dire il
y a qu'une seule nation en France moi je
prendrai les paroles de Pierre Joxe
quand le statut sur la Corse ou disait
peuple corse partie intégrante du peuple
français les nations c'est aussi partagé
un destin commun un projet commun vous
ressentez ça vis-à-vis de l'ensemble du
territoire français alors oui
nous partageons des choses en tant que
Français mais nous partageons des choses
aussi simplement tant que Breton et
alors moi si j'ai envie de devenir
breton dans votre conception de la
nationalité je peux comme ça devenir et
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire vous habitez
en Bretagne si je viens vivre en
Bretagne je peux vous êtes menton c'est
tout bon très bien pour moi c'est très
simple on est sur un territoire ce
territoire il suinte d'une histoire
d'une culture vous venez là vous faites
avec les autres ben vous en faites
partie à l'Assemblée vous avez été
membre des groupes écologistes
socialistes la République en marche et
enfin liberté et territoire qui est
devenu l'iode aujourd'hui mais vous
n'avez jamais aidé un parti vous l'avez
évoqué d'un mot mais pourquoi
je me sens pas à l'aise dans les parties
j'aime pas les embrigadements les on
vous dit voilà faut faire comme ça en
général on trouve toujours des petits
chefs qui viennent vous dire ce que vous
avez à faire comment vous devez penser
et ça je suis un peu trop indépendant
pour ça c'est pour ça que vous avez
quitté d'abord les groupes le groupe
écologistes le groupe socialiste et puis
en 2017 vous avez
vous pouvez soutenir le gouvernement
tantôt on lui expliquant que certaines
choses ne sont pas possibles or là c'est
la deuxième raison que vous aviez pas
votre mot à dire quoi bah c'était le cas
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans le groupe
liotte qui rassemble des élus Corse des
ultramarins pas mal d'élus qui sont en
rupture avec leur famille politique
d'origine on a l'impression que votre
point commun à tous et d'être un peu un
casables au sens propre du terme vous
rentrez pas dans les cases mais est-ce
que ça fait une ligne politique
si vous regardez nos votes vous verrez
que oui parce que certaines libertés de
votre quand même au sein de ce groupe il
y a une liberté de vote mais quand on
regarde bien on se retrouve à peu près
sur ces questions dont on parle en fait
ce qui nous caractérise je crois c'est
un grand pragmatisme donc les grandes
idées c'est bien
mais si elle s'incarne pas avec des
choses réelles c'est du blabla donc ça
on est là dessus on est aussi on a tous
une sensibilité par rapport à un autre
territoires d'origine
c'est intrinsèque au groupe c'est
intrinsèque au groupe c'est l'heure de
notre quiz à présent je vous explique le
principe c'est assez simple je vais
commencer des phrases ça va être à vous
de déterminer c'est bon on y va on
commence quand un député breton
rencontre un député Corse
il se parle il se parle en quelle langue
alors il se parle en français et ils se
comprennent d'accord très souvent
j'aurais gagné mon combat alors le
combat pour la culture bretonne le jour
où le jour où on proposera
l'enseignement du breton dans toutes les
écoles en Bretagne ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui ce qui est vraiment pas
le cas aujourd'hui entre chanter sur
scène ou prendre la parole dans
l'hémicycle
si vous deviez choisir c'est plus
plaisant de chanter sur scène dans
l'hémicycle on défend des choses qui
sont de l'organisation globale et
qu'est-ce qui vous tient le plus à cœur
parce que je dis ça parce que vous êtes
chanteur dans un groupe breton qui
s'appelle fear
oui les deux me tiennent à cœur c'est
c'est complémentaire
on va on va écouter quelques notes
justement vous allez sans doute les
reconnaître
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour trouver
c'est vous qui êtes en train de chanter
la ridée
[Musique]
et ça ce sera ça fera partie de votre
vie après l'Assemblée nationale ça fera
partie de ma vie je pense jusqu'au
jusque jusqu'au moment où je pourrais
plus monter sur scène et ben on va on va
terminer en musique avec sa merci
beaucoup Paul Molac d'être venu dans la
politique et moi merci beaucoup de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]